[Music]
[Applause]
Will Ferrell there ready to do sure
actor comedian former Saturday Night
Live cast member and uh co-starring with
Reese Witherspoon in court you're
cordially invited which hits theaters
July 14th uh will it's great to hear
from you again how are you doing
I'm doing great Dan
um I've never been told I have a funny
face I've been told I have a fat face
okay
yeah okay but if I said to you you have
a funny face when you come on green is
that immediate a compliment
immediately offended
okay I mean okay immediately if that is
okay yeah all right yeah my bad I I
thought that I was giving Adam DeVine a
compliment and I I just said that he
makes me laugh and and I said you have a
funny face I don't know did you take it
did you take it the wrong way
uh let's put it this way he he took it a
little better than the comment I gave
Jonah Hill a few years ago will
[Laughter]
I remember that as you've been known to
remind me of uh of that comment with the
with Jonah Hill okay that was uh that
that moment got spicy that was spicy it
did I did okay before I uh I get an
answer from you and I don't know if
you're stalling if you're not going to
go to Dublin but hold on because you're
in a movie with Reese Witherspoon it's
called You're cordially invited and
you're not coming on to talk about the
movie I mean I'm just bringing that up
but thank you I appreciate that yes and
I I appreciate you you joining us so
that's in theaters on July 14th who
wants to take a guess on your cordially
invited what is the plot for uh Will
Ferrell and Reese Witherspoon
Todd I'm gonna say they're a married
couple and they've been working all
these months and putting something
together for their son or daughter's
wedding and there's just a bunch of
calamities and one messed up thing
happens after the end all right so
anyway Seton O'Connor you're cordially
invited I think that they are high
school sweethearts
[Music]
through some weird chain of events get
reunited oh they get back together yeah
or they're put somewhere together again
they hook up yeah or maybe it goes
poorly I don't know okay
um Marvin
will brings back the Chas Reinhold
character
oh damn
feather spoon okay Paulie well before I
heard the title I heard those two were
in a movie together I thought maybe it's
like a high school reunion will was like
the guy guy who made it he's like a
billionaire and he goes back to high
school and his old Crush was Reese
Witherspoon but she crushed him and now
it's like payback time it's off some
fashion okay retribution yeah you're
cordially invited Reese Witherspoon is
planning her sister's perfect wedding
and the father is Will Ferrell of a
young bride-to-be they discover they
double booked their destination wedding
at a remote Resort off an island of the
in the uh the Georgia coast Atlanta
Georgia both parties decide to share the
small venue chaos ensues and disaster
awaits
yes well they left out the part two it's
a body switching movie
you you and Reese Witherspoon exactly I
love it so we shake hands at one point
and I become her and she becomes me uh
uh once again everybody wants to know
Reese Witherspoon
Good Kisser
uh
this is the perfect time to ask me that
question because yesterday we had
our kissing scene wow wow
no wonder I didn't hear back from you
yesterday
[Laughter]
did you take did you flub a take to
continue to make out with Reese
Witherspoon
let's just put it Disney we we did our
first take and then she said I'm good I
think we got it
she wanted no part of that she was like
I think we're good okay I think that was
great no she is she's uh she's a she's a
lovely kisser of course awkward
but we did a kissing scene and then I
did a scene where I wrestled an
animatronic alligator so that was my day
yesterday okay okay so that's that's
good enough reasons to not hear from you
about Dublin so let's recap let's go
back to
2016.16. that's how long this is that's
how long this is yes okay okay yeah so
2016 I'm talking to Jason Sudeikis we
had talked about maybe doing a show
going to Ireland you called in you
interrupted the interview you said hey
you ever go I'm all in and then it felt
like every two years you would remind me
that take if you ever go let me know
so covet hit we weren't able to go and
then finally on Monday I got the
go-ahead we're gonna do three shows
Notre Dame Navy is going to be there and
I thought I said to the Danette do I ask
will like now it's real and and now am I
gonna guilt you into going and and then
you know fritzy said no no no will hey
he's either going or he's not and then
he's a busy guy and I said okay so here
we go here's the question
are you going to join us in Dublin at
the end of August
Dan I hate to tell you this I've booked
a cruise
okay that's fair enough
I'm uh
no I am I am coming
yeah wow there will be one former James
Joyce award recipient amongst your team
and that's Will Ferrell okay you'll be
in the midst of a James Joyce recipient
all right as soon as I find out what
that means I'm gonna be really look it
up proud you look it up okay so is that
the Umpire Jim Joyce
yes he's beloved in Ireland okay for
some reason
they give an award to people in the Arts
who who call him like they see them okay
now do you want to be are you going to
be how many shows do you want to be
involved in and what role do you want to
play when you go over there
I'm I'm I'm just I'm one of the danettes
okay I'm just I'm I'm there I'm
I'm all running get coffee uh I'll I'll
I'll chime in uh I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna I'm gonna be I'm gonna be one
of the game I'll be okay
I'll be probably our kind of our
cultural administrator I've already set
up tours of the Book of Kells yeah the
Trinity College yeah uh uh uh the
Guinness Factory
um Dublin Castle uh the Guinness Factory
um uh but we'll walk the banks of the
Liffey River
we'll go we'll go to the Guinness
Factory yeah that's three times you've
mentioned the Guinness Factory oh okay
okay all right but
but yeah I'm I'm there I'm
there I'm utility guy think of me as
your Bert campanaris okay a guy who can
play all positions all nine positions
yeah all right you're like a Cesar Tovar
you're uh you're going to be a a nine
tool players which you're going to be
and I'm I'm working on
lining up a special guest
surprise guest really
Irish rock star
with the name that rhymes with Bono so
uh so no hint I'm gonna leave that up to
you if you want to see if Bono wants to
join us
I'll I'll let you yeah I'll let you work
on that that's going to be my one main
contribution I'm gonna try to get
in studio all right
um the other question that I have
can you drink
do I need a passport to go to ion by the
way yeah I think it's best
okay got it um I need to get to work on
that can you can you drink
uh yeah um
yeah my last name's Farrell
uh I'm Irish oh okay all right for some
reason I just didn't look at you as
being Irish
no I'm uh at least that's what we claim
okay that's fine
uh now we have three hotel rooms to
split amongst uh the six of us uh I'm
assuming that you're good with that
uh as long as like in room with fritzy
again
that's good that that's a deal yeah Todd
you okay with rooming with Will Ferrell
I'm absolutely fine I tend to snore a
bit but if you can deal with that then
we're good that's the least of his
worries with you
sleep apnea is can I suggest Dan can I
suggest I'm assuming all three hotel
rooms will be a joining room yes yes
okay what I would suggest is we uh you
know all our Step Brothers we build bunk
beds in one room
and then we save the other two rooms for
activities
I love this I love it yeah we could
build forts and then we'll have another
room that could be you know wrestling uh
maybe
and crafts
yeah some pottery yeah did you okay
first of all or last of all did you
clear this with your wife that you're
going to Ireland at the end of August uh
I'll be telling her
I'll be telling her in the next 24 hours
okay just just clear that with her and
last time I had you on you said that you
were going to invite Jennifer Gardner
which her name is Jennifer Garner and uh
you drop off your kids at the same place
yeah and then you said Paul Rudd might
join us as well I did reach out to Rudd
and uh he got back to me I'm gonna I'm
gonna follow up with Rudd he said he
said he would be up for it if uh you
know if schedules permitting so now I'm
going to follow the thread and see
that's exactly
exactly if you can dial it down okay and
Jennifer Gardner or Garner is not going
to be joining us
we'll not be making okay fair enough
Jennifer Gardner will be there for sure
um all right well um are you still
filming the movie
uh we we actually just wrapped our last
day was kissing and wrestling an
alligator
he was an action-packed there all right
um very proud of you and thanks again uh
well are you just gonna I'm very excited
I'm very excited about this I'm glad you
you finally pulled it together are there
any needs demands anything that I need
to like are you going to be a celebrity
are you going to be like a Danette
because I I'm going to treat you
differently
well I'll have my security team okay
and rightfully so Steven Seagal will be
joining you is what you're saying
the doll will be there and uh we have uh
three guys formerly of the Israeli
massage
so it's a fun group okay yeah I'll bet
lighthearted okay I'll be in touch
that's uh that's well Will Ferrell's
gonna join us
all right
and Reese Witherspoon is a good kisser
you're cordially invited which is
hitting theaters July 14th